months into crisis the Prime Minister
arriving to make his fast statement the
Commons on coronavirus setting out the
government's plan to begin easing the
lockdown whilst also preventing the
spread of the disease I'll be candid
with the house this is a supremely
difficult balance to strike there could
be no greater mistake than to jeopardize
everything we've striven to achieve by
proceeding too far and too fast into
lockdown as one United Kingdom but
coming out not so simple whatever he
might wish different parts of the UK may
need to stay in full lockdown longer but
any divergence should only be short-term
because as Prime Minister of the UK I am
in no doubt that we must defeat this
threat and face the challenge of
recovery together
the Prime Minister wants unity but he
also needs to get the economy moving
anyone who cannot work from home should
be actively encouraged to go to work in
sectors that are allowed to be open we
want everyone traveling to work to be
safe so people should continue to avoid
public transport wherever possible and
new steps to stay safe we would now
advise people to wear a cloth face
covering in enclosed spaces where social
distancing is not always possible and
when it comes to socializing changes to
you can now walk sit and rest in parks
you can play sports and exercise and you
can do all these things with members of
your household your own household or
with one other person from another
household provided you observe social
distancing and remain two metres upon I
do hope that's clear not clear enough
for the leader of the Opposition what
the country needs at this time is
clarity and reassurance and at the
moment both are in pretty short supply
there are lots of questions but so far
precious few answers people need
reassurance of bubble else they need it
in the next 48 hours
so can the promise to now please provide
that
clarity everybody understands what we
are trying to do together and that is
that is working together as a country to
obey the social distancing rules and to
apply their common sense and making
sense of the new message not that
different from the old one stay alert
control the virus and save lives
staying alert for the vast majority of
people still means staying at home as
much as possible extraordinary measures
and they may not all be temporary
you acknowledge today that we may never
find a vaccine should we be preparing
for our changes to our lives not just in
2020 but permanently I hope hope hope
that we will achieve a vaccine and and
develop a vaccine that can because I can
defeat the the virus and I'm hearing all
sorts of positive noises but you know
you're perfectly right Beth to to point
out that this is by no means guaranteed
am I absolutely certain that we won't be
living with this for a long time to come
I can't I can't say that it may be that
we have to become ever more flexible
ever more agile ever more ever smarter
in the way that we tackle and not just
this infection but potentially future
infections in Westminster the PM keen to
get things moving lockdown hurts the
public pass and public health but other
national leaders see danger there will
of course be risks whenever we start to
ease the lockdown but my judgment right
now is that the risk is still too great
as we lift this lock down different
nations different workers different age
groups face different risks altogether
for the past few weeks now time to take
different paths
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster